i've had numerous nights and days
thinking about leaving the bubble
i think everyone has including you guys
well i'm just saying i don't think it's
not one person that has not had a mind
that says oh my god the hell out of it
don't question what
are you gonna come to the bubble but you
know she is sure
okay so while i'm waiting for sound i'm
trying to draft my fantasy team
this is multitasking in the bubble
so i have been in the bubble since july
12th there have been
good moments bad moments lonely moments
happy moments it's just been a
big rollercoaster of emotions but
we are now here and it is the start of
round two
of the nba playoffs
[Music]
[Applause]
last night the miami heat get a huge win
over
iannis and the milwaukee bucks so it's
only right we gonna check out their
practice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you well obviously being good yeah
ooh drop the skin camera to me
[Music]
hey no gassy he better make me
[Music]
x
thanks for giving us our attacks
[Music]
you know whenever you have that you
can't cling on just one guy
we got so many guys that are constantly
working on the game they get to pick and
choose their spots
you know talking will choose for us a
band was used for us
no tyler gorham
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
max
[Applause]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no he made it did he
it what
no oh you're lying it didn't count did
it
successful no they got it they got to
review that
i don't think that i don't
hey
[Music]
hi i love your pink
dress it's so cute
what's your name
you want to be in the interviews tonight
with doritos on your face
she's precious shelby got you
got doritos all on your face your mama's
gonna kill me you know that right
i'm just gonna say that at this point
the playoff raptors are pretty
synonymous with
clutch shots what did you say yeah for
sure luckily
yeah luckily absolutely i mean hawaii's
four bounce game winner
og's big shot in game three i mean what
are the similarities that you saw
between those two shots
um crazy shots that nobody thought were
going in
last second buzzer beaters in the
playoffs are you know kind of rare i
know it doesn't seem that way now being
in the bubble but
historically it seems rare and you don't
see many of them so
i'm just glad to be a part of both and
you want to keep advancing this time of
year you got to have some of those
yeah i mean you talk about being a part
of both it's kind of crazy because you
were actually the primary option
on lt's game winner i mean how was it
supposed to play out yeah
well in the perfect world i would have
ran right to the ball caught it and
shot it but you know i was able to draw
a little attention and
i think they fell asleep a little bit
and og stepped up and knocked it down so
that was big for us for sure
okay the match-up we wanted to see
lakers taking on the rockets headed to
that game
right now
[Music]
basket
[Music]
this lakers rockets game one getting a
little chippy
i think we might see a brawl or two not
a bra
but it's gonna be very aggressive this
series i can tell
leaving the raptor celtics game i
checked the score for clippers nuggets
and the nuggets are up 45-24 into the
[Music]
first
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay um definitely been a rough
like 24 hours rough time um while i'm
here in the bubble
my great uncle passed away for those of
you that don't know
lou brock is my great uncle
he was a hall of famer with the st louis
cardinals one of the best to
ever play the game but um
for me i just lost somebody that i love
dearly and one of the best people that
you will ever meet in your life he is
kind and genuine and funny and caring
and made every single person that he
came across
feel like the most important person in
the world and while i know some people
believe that his gift was baseball i
think that
was his actual gift making all people
feel seen and heard and amazing
he really did have a knack for that but
yeah so that is what's going on with me
here in the bubble
definitely been rough rough rough
time but one thing that really did lift
my spirits was seeing jason tatum
who was from st louis he's wearing his
cardinal jordan 34s
and he wrote rip blue brock
obviously everybody knows he played for
the same goes garden
um one of the best players ever
and the mlb one of the best players to
play photographs
um 22 i never got the same play but i
know what he means
just wanted to share some light on that
um back home that warmed my heart
because i know
my uncle would have loved him i loved
them
and yeah so that was a little that was a
little light
um in a dark dark couple days
[Music]
okay not only are the nuggets winning
over the clippers michael porter jr had
one of the
best dunks huge poster
[Applause]
hello so at a lot of these games
obviously people have family here but it
seems like you all have a big family
section i can hear them a little more
than the others
how does it affect the way you guys play
can you hear them the same as we can
it's just good to have a support system
for a lot of guys we came into this
bubble with the idea that we were going
to be here for the long haul we were
prepared for the long call i think our
families
were prepared for that process as well
so we follow through with them coming
here and everybody has that support
system but it's going to be important
coming down the stretch you know just to
have some people
uh the lack of fans in the building for
us to have a group of people that's here
for us that's great
but does the energy feel different now
as opposed to before the family still
can't hear them for real
it's good all right thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
double occ baby
okay so i might just be hype but that
was one of the best playoff games
ever double ot what is showing from the
raptors and the celtics
even had a bit of a like a weird scuffle
scrum
in the end when they were headed to the
locker room i recorded that
i also asked jaylen brown what that even
was
you guys were heading back to the locker
room it seemed like the teams were
exchanging
words you know what happened there what
was that about
uh you know a lot of emotions
things like that swirling et cetera
i ain't going to really speak on it too
much
but you know it's a lot of emotions it's
an intense series
so you know things like that packing up
the spot
saying goodbye to the bubble
adios
uh i'm actually kind of sad
game for lakers rockets it's my
final game of the bubble
but um right now it's 26 22 lakers
a lot of game left see you guys
[Music]
final night um in the bubble
so i wrote an instagram caption but i
feel like i need to share it first with
you all the viewers of the blog
um alright so this is what it says in
the morning
i leave the bubble heading to st louis
to be with my family as you remember the
amazing life of my uncle lou
these two months have been the most
memorable and important moments of my
career
hello world i'm here
there are a few times in life that you
get to be a part of a first
and then only
this layered experience came in the
midst of a country dealing with systemic
racism
police brutality and a devastating
pandemic
players sought out players use their
voices players battled with an array of
deep emotions while still competing for
a championship
every day i asked myself how to best do
my job to convey this story
being deliberate with questions taking
videos of sounds and moments that
mattered but also capturing the joy and
levity that presented itself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one day people will make movies and
write books about this time
this was history i feel blessed and
thankful
that i was able to record history
uh and i'm so thankful to all of you
that followed along but there are so
many more games to be played
and more changes to be made peace and
love